il y avait trois objectifs que j'avais à
signal à la loi de sur la croissance
verte c'était lutter bien sûr contre le
réchauffement climatique c'était ensuite
réduire la facture énergétique qui est
de 70 milliards de déficits de la
balance commerciale à ce moment-là et
c'était développé des filières de
compétitivité et d'innovation dans ce
domaine avec deux outils opérationnels
parce que j'ai toujours pensé que le
local le Global c'est-à-dire
l'international comme 21 le National les
stratégies nationales et le local les
territoires et les citoyens doivent tous
tirer dans la même direction si on veut
des résultats et dans cette loi donc
j'ai créé les territoires énergétiques
avec en particulier parce que c'était la
première préoccupation des élus c'est
l'isolation des bâtiments municipaux en
particulier pour faire des économies
d'énergie d'une part et puis le crédit
d'impôt de transition énergétique qui
permettait aux particuliers sans
condition de ressources parce que
j'estimais qu'on était dans une
transition énergétique et
permet à tout le monde de se remettre à
niveau sur l'isolation des logements le
crédit d'impôt donc je dis bien le
crédit d'impôt c'est à dire que les gens
qui n'étaient pas imposables avaient
donc ce crédit qui leur était apporté
pour pouvoir faire des travaux parce
qu'on disait quand on vous dit il y a
pas de conditions de revenus non et donc
ceux qui payent pas d'impôts n'en
bénéficient pas non c'était pas une
déduction fiscale c'est un crédit
d'impôt donc il recevait le versement de
l'équivalent de de l'investissement donc
c'était 8000 euros par personne seule et
15000 euros pour un couple 16000 euros
pour un couple de déduction fiscale
davantage davantage fiscal pour les
travaux de d'énergie
d'efficacité énergétique
et Madame là Président vous avez raison
de dire que la performance énergétique
ça concerne les bâtis les bâtiments ils
avaient dit les deux tiers c'était avant
les transports on l'oublie parce que le
transport on voit l'essence mais non
c'est bien le bâtiment qui consomme le
plus d'énergie avant les transports et
même avant l'industrie donc c'est
considérable en fait donc le potentiel
il est considérable et ce qui est
intéressant dans cette filière c'est
comme je viens de le dire c'est qu'il y
a la fois des décisions individuelles
des décisions municipales des décisions
départementales des décisions régionales
des décisions nationales des décisions
de l'industrie aussi parce qu'il y a des
bâtiments industriels il y a des
bâtiments commerciaux il y a des
aéroports qui devraient complètement il
devrait y avoir déjà des centrales
solaires sur tous les aéroports français
sans parler de la récupération d'eau
pluie qui pourrait laver les avions au
lieu d'utiliser l'eau potable enfin bon
un peu trop lent mais tout ça avait été
dit pendant les débats de et ça c'est
vraiment consensuel parce que tout le
monde quel que soit vous voyez les
partis politiques les groupes politiques
ça c'est vraiment des sujets je me
souviens dans la loi transition
énergétique et en passionné tout le
monde est vraiment les les votes étaient
acquis à l'unanimité